All right.
Amy Davies, thank you so much
for joining me.
Thank you so much for having me.
I'm really excited to do this.
I am extremely excited to do this
because I think that what you're doing
is so so relevant
to the unfortunate events
that have occurred in 2020.
Now, the interesting thing is that
I was watching a lot of the content
about First 30, a startup to help
both the onboarding
and outplacing of employees.
So, I saw, for example,
a video from September of 2019
talking about how relevant it is
to help people
as they transition to different jobs.
And then, I can't help
but reflect on March and April of 2020
with the massive layoffs
and how difficult that was.
And thinking that there are now
these platforms like First 30,
which make it easier,
especially emotionally
for the individuals,
not just for the company.
The individuals are I know, the focus,
especially in your work.
But before we get to that,
I'd love to hear a little bit about you.
Where do you come from?
I know you're in Toronto,
but where does your journey start from?
And how do you get to work
in the space of onboarding
and outplacement of employees?
Yeah. Well, thanks.
I started my journey,
I guess I started,
I studied sociology in university.
I was always really interested in people
and groups of people
and how they function.
And then, I went and moved to Europe
for about six years after graduation.
I wanted to live in a different society.
I wasn't brave enough to go somewhere
where I didn't speak the language,
but I did live in England.
And actually for a short time I also lived
in a very small town in Switzerland.
In Gommiswald Switzerland.
Yeah, I was an au pair
for a summer up there
and it was amazing.
But I lived and worked in England
and traveled all around Europe
a number of times, actually.
And I started working in market research.
And I actually read a book called,
"What Color Is Your Parachute?"
And that book,
I mean, people laughed
because it's like supposed to tell you
spit out what you're supposed to do.
And it was so accurate for me.
And I got into, I actually,
this was an interesting story.
I started working at Unilever.
I was a temp employee.
I got that job through a friend who said,
"Unilever is the best place to be a temp."
"I'm going to get you in there."
So, it's great to have a good network.
And then I was typing menus.
I typed menus for the cafeteria.
And I did a very bad job.
Anyway, I really loved the company.
And the minute I walked in, I'm like,
"I belong here."
I love the people.
And I started applying for jobs
internally there in research.
So, there was a job
on the strategy team and I got it.
And actually, there was
a really tough competition for the job.
But I think it was just because,
and this is what I always tell people is,
make sure not just networking
with your external network,
but also networking internally
at your job.
So, within a few months I started work,
go went from typing menus
to doing strategy
for the future of the business.
And so, that's where it began.
And then over the years
I had different market research jobs.
I came back to Canada
and started working for companies here.
I worked for Rogers, for Mars Wrigley,
and then I also worked
for Grainger Canada.
And really enjoyed it,
but always had this idea
that I wanted to help people
with their careers.
Every business I worked with,
beginning with Unilever,
all had mass restructures
when I was there.
And I saw the emotional toll
it took on people.
And even the people that didn't leave,
having survivor's guilt, staying
and not really trusting
the organization anymore,
I think one big miss
for companies right now is that
there are a lot of great companies
take care of their people
that are exiting the business,
but they're not really thinking about
how to take care of the people
who are staying behind.
Who are left.
Yeah. Because their productivity
is affected, their commitment
to the business is affected.
And people fundamentally,
and I learned this
when I did market research,
we feel most unwell
and we're seeing it
with covid right now,
when we feel out of control
of our own outcome.
That impacts our well-being so badly.
And when organizations go through change,
what happens is people think
they don't have control
over their own outcome.
So, one of the most important aspects
of doing the type of work that I do
is making sure people understand
how they can take control back.
That's so fascinating,
I have to say that.
Because I was reading the other day
for I guess the third or fourth time
the letter that the CEO of Airbnb
sent to their employees
when they had the massive layoffs.
And I was so impressed
with how they were dealing
with the communication.
And over communicating
and making it a reasonable
expectation experience for the employees.
And I never stopped to think about
how it impacts the other employees
that are staying.
Since covid, all the media
has been talking about is how the leaders
are communicating externally
to the ones who are leaving
and taking care of them.
But I don't think there's been
any real coverage about how employers
are looking internally
and working on the culture.
So, I think
it's a really fascinating thing
that you're bringing up here.
Yeah. I agree with you.
We just assume people will just snap back.
But I've been through so many restructures
and sometimes my role has been affected.
It's always been affected
in the sense I've change teams,
change leadership.
Not always lost my job,
but I see that even six months,
a year later,
people still talk about that day
when their colleagues were laid off
and they have a lot of pain
associated with that
and the insecurity around it.
Right, right.
Okay. So, you've gone through
these mass restructurings,
which is obviously an inevitable part
of many many companies,
it's also a natural part
as companies progress and they pivot
and they have to change strategy.
And then, how do you come
to this idea for First 30?
Because companies have been onboarding
and outplacing employees
for hundreds of years, right?
I mean, this is the natural thing to do
in the company.
So, where does this idea come from?
Yeah. Well, I want to just point out
that I agree with you there.
It is natural companies
need to restructure.
So, I do believe that companies
need to do this.
And I do also believe there's right ways
and wrong ways to do it.
And I talk about a lot about the fact
and part of the title of my book is
all about living in a reorg world.
So, what happened with First 30 was,
I was put through
two different outplacements
over the course of my career.
And I thought,
"Wow, this is so great
to be given the service."
But the whole time I thought,
"Oh, there's something different
we can be doing."
And then, of course, I naturally did.
What I do best was, I started researching.
And I found out how expensive,
first of all, the outplacement companies
were for businesses.
So, outplacement companies
can charge anywhere from about
$3,000 to about $15,000 per employee.
I don't think a lot of people are aware.
Yes.
No. That's crazy. Wait.
But what do they do,
these outplacement companies?
What are their role in there?
Yeah. There's all kinds
of different things.
So, people can get together
for group sessions to come in
and have a presentation on a topic
like branding yourself or networking,
all kinds of different topics.
They can get their resumes reviewed.
They can have a coach work with them.
But then, so, the coaches
what is costing the company
the most money.
That one to one personal coaching.
And employees,
so, they're exiting employees.
I know this because I did research
with dozens of people.
I'm always on the phone a friend
for anyone who loses their job.
So, of course,
I treated it like a research project.
I had my list of questions.
And so, the way that the personal coaches
were described to me
was that they were formulaic
in their approach.
And that the person
didn't really get their industry;
they didn't get their work level;
and they didn't really get them
as a person.
So, that was one of the things they said
they were most excited about
about these programs,
but it's what disappointed them the most
because of their expectation was so great.
So, that's when I thought about
how could I put together a program
that had a lot of virtual components
that gave them a strong connection with it
and also took them along a journey.
And the other thing that
there was a big pain point,
you could do a little blooper reel
from this.
I guess you're putting it all in,
you don't edit, right?
That's the beauty of it.
Yeah.
The other pain point was that
when they get on online portals,
because a lot of these businesses
set up online portals,
it was like a resource dump.
So, there was all these resources.
And then, you know you're stressed
and anxious, so, the way
that I organized First 30
was very thoughtful.
So, it's so clear.
if you've got a job interview,
you know exactly where to go
in that program
to get the help that you need.
But we also do all of the same things
that these outplacement businesses do,
we do resume reviews;
we have a great resume expert,
she come here to follow.
And she actually does videos
and she'll review people's resume on video
and then it will be sent to them
so they can see exactly
what they need to do to change.
And they always have that video saved.
And so, I really tried to find
the best of the best.
It's really important to me to work
with the very very best people
and provide the absolute best service.
It just so happens,
because of the approach we've taken,
we can also do it
out of a fraction of the cost
of traditional outplacement companies.
So, just for the high level sake,
the idea behind First 30 is an alternative
to these very expensive
outplacement companies
that an organization that is going through
a restructuring or layoffs or onboarding,
they can come to First 30,
which is an online platform
that is personalized to the person
who's going through the layoff
or the onboarding
and gives them personal resources,
whether it be doing their own branding;
their resume revamp;
understanding what other opportunities
there are;
and understanding, I'm guessing,
that the whole way
of how this is going to happen, right?
Because I'm sure
there are a lot of questions for somebody
who is getting laid off.
Like what's going to happen
with my compensation,
what do I have to take care of now, right?
Yeah. So, there's not a lot
on the compensation part
because we are not lawyers.
And so, it's really important that
if they have those types of questions,
there's all kinds of lawyers
that they can contact.
And that is what
I would recommend to people
if they feel like they need to review that
with their employer.
But we do give them all kinds of,
so, it starts
at the beginning of the journey
like how they must be feeling.
Right away they need
our clinical psychologist, Dr. Marilyn,
who's in the program.
And she talks to them
about how to move forward.
It's all about moving forward
and taking control.
Taking care of your well-being,
but also growing as a professional.
Sorry.
The only thing I was going to add is
every two weeks or so,
we also run webinars.
I'm always there.
Sometimes I bring in an expert guest.
And I love the way that you do this,
because this is the way
we do our webinars.
We're talking with each other.
I'm trying to open it up now
so the audience members
can start contributing.
So, we do these all the time
and they're very organized
because there's a very clear purpose
and clear outtakes.
But they're also very open
and I've been there.
So, I'm not talking at anybody.
We're having a conversation together.
And that's the beauty of the program.
Right. And it's all about the individual
at the end, right?
So, one of the things also,
I think that it's part of the focus
in your book is this idea
of individual empowerment
and not just looking at it
from an organizational perspective,
but looking at how each individual
is going to go through
this difficult process of outplacement
or the happy but complicated process
of onboarding, right?
Yeah. The book itself,
the book is called,
A Spark in the Dark:
Illuminating your path
to a brilliant career in a reorg world.
So, the book has been published.
That's on Amazon.
It's also for people, for companies
who register their employees
in the program.
It's in the program too.
The audio edition
is actually being launched
to the public in September.
Oh, congrats.
Thank you.
That book is all about
really what the world looks like, today,
what the career world looks like.
Of course, covid has had a huge impact.
And the book was written before that.
But it actually is a great book to read
when you're going and you're really trying
to make have a successful career
in this world, because that's precisely
what I'm talking about.
It answers the question,
"How do you have a successful career
when you're losing or changing your job
every two to three years?"
Because nobody's doing it for you.
I always hear this being said,
that no one cares more
about your career than you.
So, you better take the helm
and do something
because it's not just going to happen.
And I fear that, I always make the joke
that the next book that I'm going to write
is how to raise kids other people like
because likability
is so strongly connected
to your career outcome.
But I think so many people
are going into the corporate world
and with very loving parents
who have told them
that they're really good
at so many things.
And I fear that they're going out there
and finding out that it's,
we may be special to our loved ones,
but we're not going to be treated
like we're special in the world.
And because being special, it is special.
Like you're different than everybody else.
And of course, we all have
our unique abilities.
We're special to the people we love,
but we're not necessarily special,
if that makes sense.
I hate to say that. It's such a gloomy.
But when you get out in your career,
that's one of the first things
that people realize is that
you got to do the tough work.
I've done it, you know.
I'm sure you're doing it
like you're in school,
you're starting a career,
like you're doing the tough slog
to get there.
It doesn't all happen overnight, right?
Right. So, what are some
of the key insights that you've gained
over the past few years
understanding this ecosystem?
So, as you know,
as a young entrepreneur myself,
going on my journey
and a lot of my friends
who are running companies,
what are some key things
that we need to keep in mind
from a leadership perspective
on the whole process of onboarding
and outplacing employees,
except, of course, from using First 30
as an aid for our people?
Yeah. Well, I do think
that you have to consider the benefits.
When you on board
your employees very well,
your retention will be a lot higher.
That's proven in research.
That employees stay longer,
they're more productive right away,
and it will help
your overall employer brand
both to on board really well
with excellence,
and to treat the employees
that are leaving really well.
It's a very very small world.
I'm sure you're finding that,
especially doing all these shows.
I mean, your world
just keeps getting smaller and smaller.
I think it's great.
But I would say,
make sure that you treat people well
because it will have
a real financial impact on your business
when you do.
So, when I work with suppliers,
even I make sure
that I pay my suppliers
what they're worth.
I don't try to get them down to pricing
because why wouldn't I just pay
if it's a quality service
and they're an entrepreneur just like me.
I work with a lot of other entrepreneurs.
We have built the First 30.
Anyone who goes to the First 30 website,
it's first30ready.com,
will see the beautiful branding
on the website.
And that isn't me.
That's my designer, James White.
And he and I have an amazing relationship.
And the developers did a fantastic job.
And I do think
that it's how you treat people
just in general,
whether they're your employees
or your suppliers,
and to pay them what they're worth.
Yeah. So, I don't know if that helps.
And it's not specifically
about onboarding and outplacement,
but any entrepreneurs
going out on their own.
Do not cut corners
when it comes to how you pay people
and how you treat them
because the work will just be better.
Right?
Right.
So, obviously you're a researcher at heart
and it exudes from the conversation,
and from your journey.
What do you see
as the future of onboarding
and outplacement, let's say,
in 10, 20 years?
Do you think that the workforce
is going to continue at the trajectory of
every two to three years
you change jobs,
especially in the tech ecosystem?
Or do you expect some radical shifts
due to covid?
Well, certainly there's going to be
radical shifts due to covid.
There's new job,
new types of jobs opening up all the time.
I do believe that we're all
going to be seeing
that we're going to be having
multiple different jobs,
multiple different careers
over our career path.
That is not going to change
because the world is changing so quickly.
And what we need
in terms of specialties
and what people are capable of doing,
that will change
and it should change.
And I think people help themselves,
career professionals help themselves
by being aware that we live
in this reorg world.
So, you can get ahead of it
and keep scaling up
if you need to scale up
and looking around and see.
Never ever ever get complacent.
So, yes, I think
we're going to keep seeing the world
continue to change.
Restructuring happening
where I do like to think that
that opens up opportunities.
I don't like when I see people
lose their job,
but I certainly know what to do
to help them when they do.
So, I'm very happy
to have lunch First 30.
I think that type of business
will have a lot of potential
in the future for sure.
I love it.
Amy, 20 minutes go by way too fast
Oh, is it really at the end?
Unbelievable, right?
And I want to thank you
for being so generous with your time.
I know how busy you are.
And before we leave,
I have to ask the most important question,
three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Well, I'll use two words and a phrase,
because in the book I talk about
an illuminate exercise
where you figure out who you are
and what you want to convey
to the world.
And at every single touch point
be that person.
So, mine are, I'm strong.
I'm sincere.
And if you know me,
I make your life better.
And those are the three things that I am
and I try to convey every day
at every touch point.
Amy thank you very very much.
This was very very insightful.
And I look forward
to definitely sharing this platform
and hopefully using it myself
to empower the people
that I'll get to work with
and have a meaningful experience
for everybody.
And it's definitely something
that's hugely relevant
over the past few months especially.
But moving forward
and the trajectory of the workforce
is going, it sounds like
the right place, right time.
So, thank you very much and good luck.
Thank you. I really enjoyed this.
And all the best.
Take care.
Bye.